[Music]
the haters always say Tonya tell the
truth there's no such thing as truth
everyone has their own truth I was the
best figure skater in the world at one
point in time
call out a clean skate for Christ's sake
do not swear in front of the kid I
didn't swear you [ __ ]
[Music]
you to [ __ ] yet we need to see a
wholesome American family I didn't have
a wholesome American family you skated
like a graceless bull dyke was
embarrassed for you my entire life I've
been told when the mounds anything you
know what maybe I would we also judge on
presentation suck my dick
didn't even even the playing field
I know God shouldn't even be saying his
name Derek the press wanted me to be the
pilot crap
I never did this
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on we're with the FBI they
know something what can you tell us
about Tonya Harding
I don't know it Toni hearted huh aren't
you her bodyguard
when I was a kid did you ever love me I
made you a champion
knowing you'd hate me for it that's the
sacrifice a mother makes accursed me
[Music]
come on
frigging person bashes in their friend's
knee who would do that to a friend
you